Okay.
Eh,
but I get bored.
But if [inaudible] or [inaudible]
the hippo [inaudible] Internet
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] the new [inaudible] eh,
for Malia [inaudible] fields.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] board know.
And like, obviously then give
me [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] we saw
with the CMT roomies mom.
I'd be able to go.
Sarah [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] is the guy road
wrote is the footer contaminants like a
double on the coaches.
The Avalon scorcher I got a woman
[inaudible] or the package or like I said,
my photos because the metrics are so
incriminates Mackinder a yee embassy
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Cairo is on shock for you.
What can I take a little boy blue on?
Chuck
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] those three
kilometers in the middle of this year and
London,
those batteries [inaudible]
what right is that,
as we see note Ramos
[inaudible] and Casa workers.
So commerce,
some western Western
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] secret
[inaudible] chocolate.
But I mean [inaudible] but as to the air,
uh,
in Arabic he [inaudible] into total,
Eh, the homeowner. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] guests.
Jaan No. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] no, I know. Throw CTO.
When, uh, Dean was the studio.
[inaudible] Dawson. He,
Sally
[inaudible] [inaudible] Amigos.
This is seen as the
economic at the physio is
lonely cow hobby. Kutumia no.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] he'll
say nothing illegal. Sassy. Ah,
Eh, eh. Also [inaudible].
Yeah. This was the tomatoes,
onions.
What is the name
is [inaudible].
Oh,
there's the Kairos to stop.
London's
not
familiar is different.
Chicos cause
we'll see two lessons.
Yeah. You know, entered.
There were no, Eh,
though I fellow the theater
Cka Kroger from important.
They know. Can, I'm going to
sell UNICO failure. [inaudible]
do we still like our, the remit?
I get called a pattern video
because that's reality.
So I could go to local voice.
[inaudible] see,
no, no, no. So it's certainly,
look at the Ce Casa crispness of Lucy.
We still give me your worst
Ikea phenol copper. Know Leah,
but I can tell the story. Is the
brain Cvo, know a mobile Rhea
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a Mi me.
So
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] in Bass harbor.
That is host to host. No,
I can move on to yell and
the CCAT the Seo to our news
on business yet, but start
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] no,
c
is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] Langley's Frances and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] for the
narrow, but okay, let me say,
to be able to another
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
and [inaudible] nine videos now via
internet.
Now we are liberals night [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] ministers
Sovietica it has [inaudible] landed the
lose the battle Duma their particular
goal.
Marista [inaudible] as
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Daniel's Canela [inaudible] eh,
eh, Luna manifestation.
They'll Cairo. Nope.
Still magnificant.
Well,
Esau [inaudible] I know Sally.
Another [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and not missing DDA,
but another image squat.
Ross,
who still work at citrus message?
No,
he
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
fresh back in the moment.
This must feel, he says, don't
just come out. It will be
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] like a
mailbox Atlantis. Nobody. Low Libido,
you know, but I
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] significant
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] per
case Livalo [inaudible] six studios.
No, Lo mismo is, but also trust
is a real laborda the two,
because it's a live
[inaudible] [inaudible] per Kayla
concierge or no more than Mika Stego the
meeting.
But I said,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
he came to tell you.
the [inaudible].
Where are you? Ambitious.
Amhara. It'll quarto
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] six to [inaudible]
will swell low elap in tennis now.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or not really?
Or like Ai Intermedia,
Northera Torrijos nowadays to not be,
here are some momentum to be done
was to be, that is the ultra persona.
They see the ultra Botswana who not
in this insignificant one to everyone.
[inaudible] me. No sick.
He may have answered this.
[inaudible] and [inaudible]
is a prostate contento uh,
[inaudible] significant [inaudible] is
[inaudible] because what about the one on
one cafe? Oh, sorry.
Hello. The lapita wait.
[inaudible] I can't use message.
The lamps.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
no. Miss Beer. Foreign aunties.
No. This meal he rural.
Yes.
Meal.
Yeah. That's Ikea. But then the
[inaudible] [inaudible] house
and dedicate, they get ethylene,
didn't it?
You're going
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Forrest Gump.
This is Mr
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I'm
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
husband. You know he has money.
Amanda tourists,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. [inaudible]
so he was one on one.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] the winner this year.
And [inaudible] you were still Islam.
Cassini.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] minutia.
Classy. They will do that if he can't
sit to country, that they were those,
those company Arrows,
the central coast recipe.
And you don't know it affects at the hour.
I also hear this panel stig and under
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I said
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] who
is the headache of [inaudible] was 10
for others. The Dinero dealing
coaches, they will not go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] it.
There is Makkah you don't
know even there's the role
shown in the hip to [inaudible],
which has a problem. I say
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible].
But a lot of good Russell, so
forth. Tuner lecture your pasta.
No secret [inaudible]
broader America.
[inaudible] one the [inaudible] theater
[inaudible] understanding style and
model.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] was told the
senior marketing [inaudible]
Rao look system. No.
[inaudible] mover more fee
simple.
Say Soreness.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
as he didn't donate.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] delete case,
eh? [inaudible] Barrios. Okay.
This bleaker Mucho Internet case.
You must,
oh.
Oh Australia
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] there's the,
it was the most dollars for owners.
There's the restatement barks,
Eh,
admitted [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] as you know,
as somebody of America soon loose Romanos
keratitis module communication it all
through the current poaches [inaudible]
[inaudible] and [inaudible] wrote Carbon
[inaudible] Alberto,
no Loomis.
Most of us could join the aura.
The authors.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] not going
to be either a story. We don't.
I can be yellow Manila,
the [inaudible] with a
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] and Miss [inaudible]
two k
that
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] gate gate [inaudible]
see nostalgic or Corazon Norfund scenario.
You'll see exit out.
They go,
I can move into know
your way. I said I'll go through those
in kilowatt.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] over in
Savannah is not in Iran. I see
the Bordeaux Korea.
No ma'am.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] nor the other myth.
[inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Nilo Nyla [inaudible] [inaudible] sales
system.
I'm not going to know.
So sophistical Como estas the phenomenon
commercializer I mean the Internet
[inaudible] system at [inaudible]
the Mount Mirror
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] stimulus.
No goal with this.
The one is less VG.
Barbara Clinton was the Fiji [inaudible]
no,
Eh,
on accident.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] has the Internet.
He said, you know, it's still
a, it's double there. So no,
no salary. [inaudible] is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] as [inaudible]
sociologist Momento no [inaudible] soon.
And that elephant to learn [inaudible]
media to will [inaudible] the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
intro and remedial.
The [inaudible].
He [inaudible] into the sauna.
Our eye, which is the startups.
Our, I mean, she seemed more hubs.
It'll asanas in your own case law.
INFORMATICA [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] is the key. I mean,
they don't understand some niggers.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] industry.
Yeah, I've known that.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
no.
[inaudible]
it'll be
[inaudible] minister
[inaudible] Quatro de Niro.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
no games has been solo,
Eh,
in a hip to CDC is Finkley
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] grubby keys.
I spent [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] this
is a little bit of middle [inaudible].
No.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] oh,
well that's a new Barbara as taking notes.
A Sierra, no Baba. Wait, Yo,
what's up,
bro?
Yes
ma'am.
That's good product.
Maybe you don't like
[inaudible] Mandela. Ah, your
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so to be that,
no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
a much purposes seem correct.
You can be on, which has beat
us. [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a
[inaudible] [inaudible] meal,
those meal or she will
their CMT meals. Uh, more
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] was nothing.
Go that issue. The mark of an animal.
A pillar. We are Adelante does.
The beginners can be as diverse saunas.
You're over if you're okay,
you neither the Africa,
but if funeral, okay,
that's one of the question was
to recommend was army. Eh, like
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] whether it's like,
I don't know. Let's do the,
yes,
it is hungry for,
I can move on to your [inaudible]
or [inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] or [inaudible] to make them
better than me.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] come here. Personas.
So what does, how you got to
lose? I've been Sarah Miller.
[inaudible] [inaudible] Miranda
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] think oak.
I said it has to suit you,
but I've been sick.
Tell me what
[inaudible] [inaudible]
it
can be as a logo
personas [inaudible] but some personas,
those carbon is this [inaudible]
but then the stomach,
no, a lot calmer sweaters,
some personas and can be
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] so [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] competitors will
all know within [inaudible] and
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
throw the Kinsey been 10 years.
I can be able to starbase
you. Does that person look at it?
Mirror,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] that
are responsible for that.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] and then senior year,
so this is the beginning of the
beginning of snow over the TV.
They say chuck Labarsky
Respeto is fundamental.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Erica
Sudo [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] no,
it doesn't seem very [inaudible].
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] incubator me
Hubby, Kenya Leboldus Avalara.
The Obama Lopez is a lot of
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] theory divided up
more [inaudible] and minimal
[inaudible] as the k.
Yeah. Yeah. I can move
through. Ready for the cake?
Yeah.
[inaudible] Amanda [inaudible]
no, no, no, no, no, no. Oh.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a [inaudible]
here is the,
the lower [inaudible].
No.
[inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] and it
was the worst in California is Tomasa
lobbyists. And that isn't true.
Is there a difference here?
But a foremost Auntie's k
years a [inaudible] Bruce,
we take
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] or nausea as
tech in [inaudible] the [inaudible] the
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] so
[inaudible] [inaudible] Enoch
will be what's called a liberal
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] has endorsed it
in it. Oh, it had limited. Basically.
See that they needed,
they needed to know fantastical the
hotel de [inaudible] whenever banners.
I said
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] we
[inaudible] online dota is
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] middle [inaudible].
I can work to our references,
the [inaudible] but I said legally
supposed to move because they see,
so city misses
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] what about
[inaudible] Amigos?
Are you the central coast?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
the [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] money
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] inhibitors.
Is that HR or they check on the
Anthony [inaudible] you'll see
[inaudible] [inaudible]
owners they owned by
[inaudible] [inaudible] link
[inaudible] we took years.
We're still Nokia number in
[inaudible] who see lassie,
but at the [inaudible] no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
so sort of Internist Korea,
me stuck on the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
English sort of
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] a con.
It's a kimono.
No [inaudible] Al Capone and
[inaudible] Loomis within a cohost.
[inaudible] [inaudible] or
[inaudible] 17 [inaudible] give up.
I said,
Eh,
OnBase [inaudible] Lavandera eleague
no one knows the Hogan [inaudible] the
football [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] like
your home is the rituals.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] but
I've been their own software
or Nicosia
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
[inaudible] don't understand.
And then ranking them and 30th
then for Martha [inaudible]
no.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] they meet them.
Okay.